بعد شتاء مغلق طويل
، تحرص اللغة الإنجليزية على السفر ،
لذلك كان إعلان الجمعة
متوقعًا بفارغ الصبر
حيث كشفت الحكومة عن قائمتها الخضراء
للوجهات التي لا تتطلب
الحجر الصحي عند العودة إلى
العناوين الرئيسية لتلك القائمة هي إسرائيل والبرتغال
وأيسلندا وأستراليا
في جميع البلدان الـ 12.  آمن
بما فيه الكفاية هنا ليكون المسافرون الخالي من الحجر الصحي
من إنجلترا قادرين على
الذهاب إلى تلك الوجهات
بدءًا من 17 مايو وسيكون ذلك
مريحًا حيث تم حظر العطلات الخارجية
هنا لأشهر
، وتعتبر جميع البلدان الأخرى
إما حمراء أو كهرمانية
تركيا نيبال وجزر المالديف  تمت إضافتها
إلى القائمة الحمراء مما يعني أنه لا ينبغي على الأشخاص
السفر إلى هناك ،
وسيضطر أولئك الذين يفعلون ذلك إلى عزل أنفسهم
في فندق حكومي عند عودتهم
على نفقتهم الخاصة ،
وستتطلب دول الكهرمان التي تشمل معظم أوروبا والولايات المتحدة من المسافرين
الحجر الصحي  في المنزل وإجراء اختبارات PCR متعددة
عند عودتهم ،
يتم تصنيف البلدان بناءً على
covid1  9 معدل إصابة معدل التطعيم الخاص بهم
وانتشار المتغيرات الخطرة
التي
يتم تحديثها كل بضعة أسابيع ، لذلك هناك أمل في
أنه مع تقدم اللقاحات في
أوروبا ، سيصبح الوصول إلى
بعض الوجهات السياحية الأكثر شعبية
لرواد العطلات
أكثر سهولة بحلول
هذا الصيف
cyril vanier cnn  لندن